hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well
we've reached the end of the nostalgic
crickets resume of cinematic crap so why
not end on a high note because he's not
talented enough to boldly flee
like sci-fi movies you won't after this
this film does for science fiction what
disaster movie does for disaster movies
references left and right while never
figuring out why they need to make them
last minute drama to make up for their
lack of comedy and of course we come
full circle seeing a guy who started
from his parents basement make a video
exploding Empire resulting in him going
back to his parents basement need i say
more sadly I have to this is to boldly
flee we start off with the NC feeling
depressed over the loss of his friend
mati
of course he waits an entire year never
referencing this in any of his videos
but for the fourth year I guess he
figured it's time to think about him
again
hello hey film brain this sounds are
critic how wonderful see your voice ah
mighty you know I I never thought I'd
end up missing him you're probably
feeling guilty nah that's not it no that
will require development and ironically
we're probably gonna get way too much of
it in this one mist algae critic yeah
you're under house arrest he finds he's
being placed under house arrest because
his old friend Earl has somehow acquired
legal action and I will not rest until
he faces the coup hand up justice give
him credit for not doing any jokes with
a lawyer who represents it legal aliens
but you don't take off if they would
meanwhile some of the other channel
awesome crew hear a sound in space their
conclusion it's big whatever it is it's
gigantic is it me or does it look like
it's getting bigger
thank God we spend two minutes on that
scene things get even stranger when
apparently spoonie's mind has been
possessed by the mind of mati which
forces him to do god-awful impressions
that will later be surpassed by other
god-awful impressions help me critic
take me home meanwhile we seem link Aras
knocked out by his robot double Mecca
Cara who keeps him alive simply because
if he escaped he concealed in Cara came
out of the closet we see later that the
NC is approached by the lads angry geek
who apparently freaks him out so bad he
scares his glasses right onto it why did
you leave mati in that oatmeal
can the cremated him that usually does
the trick only his body was dead Critic
his character survived so through the
magic of surreal fourth-wall jokes we
found out that mati has left his
character in someone's mind who could it
possibly be clearly the answer lies in
the people who are no longer on the site
spoonie of course
spoonie has his character we see dr.
howard and dr. fine tried to read
spoonie's mind only to find out that
mati has truly possessed it she it's a
good thing nc called them and let them
know about the footage that they found
awake he never did that because he's
having a seventh Heaven moment with the
nostalgia chick every single time I get
one of these dreams I feel it gets
calling me someplace important someplace
where I belong someplace where I can
make a difference I just can't get
enough of the NC telling us how he feels
does he do it anymore in this special
you know just because a woman's talking
to you on a comfy chair doesn't make
this a Barbara Walters interview it's
gonna take a flight of the navigator
knock off to knock off this funk
of course wormhole Theory it's the only
way he could travel the only logical
explanation
spoonie where is the hole just point to
the doll and tell us where he touched
your hole what's he doing he's searching
through star charts computers don't have
isn't
your computers don't have any
information on Jupiter mighty starts
communicating through both spoonie's
mind and nc's computer in the hopes of
really doing nothing more than scare the
living shit out of them how by pulling
up their computers which somehow show
smoke damage and debris in one shot but
not in the other subtle bastard but a
prick named prick has come in to steal
Spoony for an evil corporate executor
which this movie seems to think always
wears evil robes and talks in
threatening voices well at least they
got something right unplugging from the
machine the scientists made wait are
they scientists or doctors maybe they're
ice cream truck drivers regardless
unplugging that seems to cause all sorts
of chaos around the world
yeah I know as if enough goes faster
references were made the NC decides
enough is enough and beans in his fellow
reviewers to his house where he asked
them for help once more please I'm I'm
begging you here
well it would be good of us to help out
our fellow reviewer yeah there will be
no one left to watch our reviews and
then there will be no one left to
criticize ya and then we won't get paid
yeah and we can only afford one more
these anniversaries anyway yeah so they
go to their scientist friend doctor and
say know who for someone who doesn't
want to help them was sure nice enough
to let them inside that explains what's
causing all this case a plot hole hole
which is backwards and backwards as
forwards to be the gateway to madness
and it's out of control
good good this is beyond fourth wall
jokes this is like if the fourth wall
had a mouse hole and the mouse hole had
four walls and they had a termite hole
and that termite hole had four walls
that's the fourth wall we'd be looking
through you know the twelfth wall so are
there any other questions I could help
out son of a bitch so they steal what
they came from in say nose place and
build the NCS house into a spaceship
think Pixar's up only with more
homoeroticism speaking of man-on-man we
get a humorous scene where Mickey finds
out from Prague that Spoony is being
held on Europa how does he find this out
I think even Charles Manson would be
squeamish to tell you the details
meanwhile the executor sends a long
General Zod to help Turrell with his
inability to well do anything Tom what
are you meant to transform this vessel
into a house but why because these
green-screen backgrounds cost a lot of
money so sure enough they transform the
ship into a McMansion
but that doesn't distract from our
reviewers doing more muggy Jesuit aku
somehow gets transformed into Ed CR
somehow gets transformed into Jordy
klopse
and Luke and snob somehow get
transformed into Will and Grace we've
got something better
what's that
a family that's a beautiful thing I
suppose snob promise me something
yeah propose before we get to Jupiter I
don't think I'm being greedy in saying
that but mecha car can't keep his drill
in his pants and starts assimilating the
crews starting with a nostalgia chick
it's about time where were you counting
the approximately four hundred and
twenty five point six two billion stars
that comprise this galaxy and using that
number to calculate the estimated travel
time to Jupiter now you might be asking
how nobody can pick up on the fact that
they're Androids but to be fair their
acting is just about as robotic as
everyone else's on the ship
so they finally reach Jupiter and send
three crew members down to rescue scooty
just as the SS leather bar shows up this
of course puts them in the greatest
crisis so far in the movie asking
yourself if they'll ever get their
security deposit back we wish for you to
beam aboard this vessel and face the
wrath of Zod and turn but mostly town so
they threatened the nc that if he
doesn't beam aboard he'll kill his crew
members down on the planet oh why would
you do that Oh
hurt so much yeah think I'll be all
right
Jesus even the people from Family Guy
would say this joke was on too long this
is worse than that time I random thing
with that famous random thing in the
non-sequitur cop wave you remember that
moment Matt oh we showed the clip but
his red shirted this caused him to come
back as they work on a plan that you
know is long and complicated and really
just exists to give you some slapstick
so here's some slapstick
you know the NC is one of the greatest
physical comedians of our time and that
you physically want to hurt him every
single time he's on screen
so he's beamed into one area that's not
right
beamed into another area that's not
right then he's been into another and
another and another and another and
another and I didn't think there was
such a thing as beaming fetish but you
know what I think the N sees got it in
all the commotion cinema snob gets
captured and taken to the executor where
he's fed the rare delicacy of Thin Mint
Girl Scout cookies hey I don't care what
Amos says those things are caviar but
the executor or at least convincing old
man makeup since prometheus convinces
the cinema snob that if he joins his
side he'd be able to transform from his
Z grade movie reviewer to Z grey movie
maker think of it mannequin mu lights
real equipment key grips and best boys
and shoes Brad again you'll last be
allowed to wear shoes in your videos
meanwhile mecha car turns Todd into a
threatening machine of cardboard and
plastic but unfortunately the crew is
too busy seeing the machine that CR and
Jo created which seems to have the power
to seem to spoonie's mind grows up shot
we don't a Latino K seriously this may
be the first time a film series gets a
sexual harassment case from a guy there
is more man skin in this movie than
leather faces wardrobe either somebody
come out of the closet or double bolt
that closet so we don't have to look at
it
they finally come across my tea or at
least the two to three actors playing
mati as he tells film brain that he's
collided with the hole which is
spreading all the chaos and that the
only way to stop it is to force the NC
to go in and if that doesn't work I
definitely have a hole E&C can climb
into the executor continues to lure the
snob but the less angry geek tries to
break in and save it
wait this special is blood happy how
come the people who often specifically
talk about sci-fi in their reviews are
the first ones to go in this movie I
will do whatever you ask cinema snob
terms like a flapjack and it suddenly
evil now which is good because it's just
in time for a film brain to learn about
it
the whoo-hoo quibble before the power of
the dead bomb Wow
mattias the plot hole can do just about
anything through the power of
implausibility so much so that you kind
of wonder why he doesn't just destroy
the nc to begin with I mean yeah we hear
later he wants the end of the world to
happen by the NCS hand but dude if the
NC destroys everything who are you gonna
glow that to what you think a few
seconds before the NC destroys
everything you're like auntie did it
have what solid plan there but the crew
has been knocked out by Team Inspector
Gadget and it's up to obscure sloop ax
and more manwhoring to save the day
touch if you fight back
I'll go out on a date with you
really so that's what was needed to snap
Todd out of it the possibility of sex
though given the nipple count in this
movie I doubt it's going to be from any
lady anytime soon
and he still not bad as gene Simmons
without his makeup so film brain fills
the men about the executor Ziva plan and
how the cinema snob is now on his side
he looks like the only thing to set this
right is a cameo brought on by the
leftover budget money for a last-minute
plane ticket help you I can mmm
give them a zap of movie brain juice
which demonstrates the power of cinema
as opposed to just the crap for every
two dozen Fanta menaces there is a
return bikini for every two-bit
Shyamalan Stanley Kubrick is born every
realisation that where the wild things
are as a brilliant movie there's another
realization that maybe the Dark Knight
Rises was incredibly stupid I'm ready
Zod and Terrell starts celebrating their
victory while the rest of the team
beamed to their separate locations to
try and distract them and good luck
getting this fucking song out of your
head for the next two weeks
actually if you look on the back of your
DVD case you'll find there's an extra
recording of ducktales just to help you
out with that this leads to explosions
fire mugging ripping off scenes from
movies that honestly aren't even really
that iconic and also the N see entering
the plot hole to find a desperate plea
to find the writer clutter and in the
anniversary I write in that you go
inside this anomaly and the only thing I
could think of that'd be really cool
inside that nomally is if you meet up
with the writer me I saw Charlie Kaufman
try this and film study classes are
still pretending like they know what
he's talking about we also see a fight
between cinema snob and his apprentice
Luke
thank God the actor playing snob is a
claustrophobic or anything oh wait he is
well we just found one person suffering
more through this movie than me I'm a
critic an artist like my father before
me your father was just an improv
comedian on Canadian television and he
resign is it anyway that wasn't exactly
Citizen Kane kid holy smokes
Luke's father is Wayne Brady yeah
actually I can see it a cinema snob is
desperate to be in at least one original
scene and brings this one to a close
come on kitty
some films are worth fighting for the
ones not premiered online don't brain
and sage go in to try and fight mighty
as well but mighty is certain that the
NC will make the choice that will
destroy them all every character has a
purpose if not why would you write them
I don't know I've been asking that all
throughout this entire movie it's up to
you
oh yeah who needs action-adventure and
space travel when you have suburbia this
is where it's at and here
you must believe boy Gamache believe
yeah it was probably just as phony
anyway yeah if you watch the ratings for
Glee you're probably right so the NC
makes the right choice and even manages
to say he's sorry to mati which warms
his heart so much he finally decides to
leave and be a piece
but because this movie wants to top
Return of the King for most unnecessary
endings the plot hole becomes unstable
and is going to destroy everything
there's only one thing to do vii the
cameos yes yes look at those cameos look
at them blue there's more cameos here
than all the Muppet movies put together
even that strange one made by Sarah
Silverman that was weird what you have
to do with the Muppets
so was the plot hole gets bigger both
literally and metaphorically the critics
watch as their doom comes closer and I
guess this is it hey remember your first
review my name is equilibrium if that
wasn't smart families absolutely hated
it I liked it I don't even remember my
first review I just remember being
really angry loving every minute of it
oh yeah I'm totally convinced they're
not gonna make it channel awesome just
fired all of them in one swoop just for
shits and giggles and yet they still
showed up to shoot their finales at the
same time onward poorly deceiving
soldiers
of course they don't die but the NC does
manage to merge with the whole in order
to keep it stable the sacrificing his
life dish I don't know can't we find the
most annoying character possible to
explain this better I can answer that
one thank you the plot hole created
havoc because we used to live in a
universe that made sense you know that
the hole is the universe there is no
conflict was the crazies for new normal
do well there will always be
inconsistencies little surprises that
make life worth living but your movies
just begun you put us like all of ours
you'll make it a good one a wizard did
it bring on the booze so everyone
parties like oh I don't know they just
survived the end of the world all of
them seeming to be pretty ok with the
fact that the end see isn't around
anymore
in fact I dare even say they totally
forgot about it but it's ok I'm sure he
has a conversation with the talkie
Parrothead opens up his umbrella and
flies away into the sky once more or
screw it let's just rip off a different
movie I am from the south
that was to pull we flee what a shock it
made me want to boldly flee these movies
are stupid cheesy obviously low-budget
and it's fairly clear it's just a chance
for the nostalgia cricket to try and
grow his eagle every single time he's on
stream hey you know what you should
really start growing a hair line or your
ability to stop parading your probable
homosexuality these films were a giant
friggin waste but I guess I can't be too
angry I mean after all this is coming
from a guy who's very similar to me
actually I dare even say eerily similar
scarily some why are you going
scarily eerily similar
my god the Nostalgia cricket is and
always has been
haleyss well they'll be a fun thing for
obscure lupa to figure out I'm the
Nostalgia crate
I remember it so you don't have to
you